Hello
Freak bitches.
You put that much emphasis on beauty being one of the defining self worth
characteristics.
Then when that starts to go,
you're in this mad fucking scramble for as much surgery as possible to restore
this youth rather than appreciating the gifts that each age bring.
Like each age should bring more wisdom and like,
like the older Abuelita's like the that you see down in the jungle that have
fucking magic that they're able to bring like,
yeah,
I'm not young and beautiful anymore,
but I've lived 65 years.
I'm tuned into my instincts and I can fucking bring magic.
I can heal with herbs.
I can do these different things.
That's all well and good,
but their Instagram ass pictures with book shit version Celta pisses on those.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Old Magic Lady in the jungle.
Look at these yoga pants,
fixtures,
fucking yoga pants or revolutionized the world changed everything,
changed the game.
Well,
you could look at a girl naked without her being naked,
but better than naked because it's all compressed like it's not.
It's not like you don't see the sloppy aspects of skin and flesh and tissue and
deposits.
Just that beautiful Preston shape and shape is so deeply ingrained in the human
brain and the colors of a flower.
Yeah.
You know,
you get your whole legs are all pink.
It's amazing.
It's a bright pink,
a shocking bright pink or white or like,
whoa,
it's a white rose,
right?
Like a total hack into our psyche.
Like the monkeys that have those colored butts
[inaudible] totally freak out the monkeys out.
What the fuck is that?
I Buy Boone Ass fucking goddamn explosion of fireworks coming out of their
asshole.
We,
they should be baboons,
nasty yoga pants.
The most popular yoga pants ever.
Maybe be too much.
They were all just all flesh color,
just all normal.
And then just fold baboons ass.
Beyond that.
No,
there's,
there's really,
uh,
quite a bit of fear of,
of,
of my speaking.
So there are mostly in Canada,
right?
Uh,
mostly in Canada and in America.
Outside magazine.
The date they quashed that story.
I mean,
this is going to be a big feature.
How did that happen?
Do you know the mechanism?
Yeah,
so the,
uh,
the writer was staying at our place and at the time I believe we had,
there were,
uh,
there were people watching us and I had specifically said because his,
his rental vehicles parked across and here he was sitting on the couch and,
you know,
we're talking and talking and I looked and it was a truck that repeatedly drove
by and stopped and went to the other in the street,
turned around.
I said,
fuck,
you're being,
you're being watched.
Like,
and he's just like,
you know,
I think at this point he didn't truly appreciate the depths that we were in.
And at this point I don't,
we weren't even sued yet.
And,
uh,
sure as shit marina and named him by name the author and uh,
and that was it.
So he wouldn't,
I mean,
he tried to get the,
the,
the article to run,
but outside ultimately said like,
we're not interested in being sued now.
It's a different time.
There's anti slap legislation now,
so outside if you're listening,
but,
well why didn't they just shut their fucking mouth until they published it?
I,
he was,
how did they find out what he was looking?
He was asking a current and former employees to see if anyone would speak.
And then obviously there was someone that went to,
you know,
when you live,
when you worked in an oppressive sort of regime,
if you will,
you're,
you're quick to try to score bonus points.
I assume the former trainer or someone probably said,
hey,
this guy's calling around looking for something.
What are the businesses that guy have?
They're all in house businesses,
but yeah,
he's got,
he owns a lot of property.
He has,
he owes no one any money.
There's no outside,
uh,
financial interest whatsoever.
He is the sole controlling mind cause it seems like God,
like that needs a come to Jesus moment.
We're just realizing it's was like,
what am I doing?
My life is,
I mean he's at the later stages of his life and just live in like this.
So when people,
it's all anger and evil and,
well I hate to mention it,
but the couple of years ago,
a few years ago,
and this was my greatest ally,
his son actually passed away and this was the guy who actually allowed me into
the park when I,
when unbenounced to me,
I was no longer allowed there.
He let me in and that's when I saw,
you know,
smooshy in the condition that she was in.
That ultimately inspired me to sort of speak out and not be anonymous.
And uh,
he shortly thereafter actually passed away and he was my age.
I think if you became a lawyer and you were arguing all the time,
you'd probably be a nightmare to be around cause you're probably always trying
to win.
I'll for sure.
Yeah.
That's what they do.
Right?
Find their way out of technicalities.
You're a shrink too and you're,
you know,
every,
every conversation you get in,
are you psychoanalyzing everybody probably,
right?
Yes,
for sure.
That's got to wear out on you other people for Awhile.
Like will you knock it the fuck off?
Yeah.
Well when I was in college that was the area.
I'm never really applied myself at college at all.
But the one thing that I was thinking of,
like if I had a job,
like what?
What are things that I'm interested in?
Psychology did come up because I'd read a lot of like self help books and
psychology books while I was fighting to try to like manage my mind and anxiety
and shit like that.
But then I thought about it.
I'd be like,
you just be dealing with people with problems all the time and you don't,
I don't necessarily want that.
I don't,
I don't think that's a good idea.
Just make you dick soft.
That's why.
Is that do it?
Yeah.
When someone tells you their problems,
I always feel like if you tell me your problems,
you're making my Dick's off problems make you dig stuff.
I've never,
well,
I always felt like that when I was dating girl.
She starts telling your problems.
You're like,
man,
you're making that ticks off.
Right.
Depends on what the problems are.
The problems with my ex boyfriend.
He just never wanted to eat pussy.
Good problem.
That's a problem.
That makes it the car,
Babe.
We've got solutions.
We've got solutions for this problem.
Problems make met Dick.
I've never heard that before.
Thank you.
But now
that's an original problems.
Make my Dick Stop.
You should make a song.
I've written a few lyrics.
Really have to wrap.
Or the way that I had it written out is that it's one of those songs that starts
with banter between like the piano player and the guy on the mic and he's like,
yeah,
you know,
hey Joe,
how'd it go last night?
He's like,
ah,
man.
You know,
she came over,
but you know,
you didn't know nothing.
I hate,
listen.
I hate more than proud.
Was like,
Oh yeah,
man.
Then you hear a little bit sprinkle of the piano.
You problems make my Dick so dick.
So that can actually be a funny song.
I think so.
Yeah,
definitely.
Yeah.
You see the team up with somebody?